Nos dicen que: "Carla tiene una torre de
42 bloques. Ella agregó 12 bloques rojos,
14 bloques azules y 16 bloques morados". Entonces,
lo que queremos hacer en este video es pensar en
cuántos bloques tiene Carla en total. Y para
ayudarnos con eso vamos a usar una pequeña recta
numérica aquí, y esta recta numérica continúa
en ambas direcciones, y voy a establecer que
esta marca gruesa sea 40, quiero asegurarme
de que puedo incluir 42 aquí, y contamos 41,
42, 43, 44, 45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50. Entonces
cada una de las marcas gruesas son 10 más,
por lo que tenemos 50, 60, 70 y 80. Lo que me
gustaría que hicieras es pausar este video,
pensar en dónde está 42 en esta recta numérica,
y luego pensar cómo agregamos estos bloques en
esta recta numérica para encontrar cuántos bloques
tiene Carla en total. Muy bien, ahora hagamos esto
juntos. Comencemos con los 42 bloques con los que
inicia, estos de aquí. Vemos que aquí está el 40,
así que vamos a 41, 42; entonces justo aquí está
el punto de partida de Carla: esto es 42 bloques.
Primero agrega 12 bloques rojos, vamos a contarlos
en la recta numérica: si sumas 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, llegamos aquí, entonces aquí
llegamos cuando sumamos 12 bloques. Pero ¿adónde
nos llevó esto? Bueno, podemos ver que tenemos
1, 2, 3, 4 después del 50, así que ahora estamos
en 54 justo allí. Y podríamos haberlo hecho de
otra manera, podrías haber sumado desde el primer
momento diciendo: Está bien, voy a sumar 12, así
que me toma 8 llegar a 50 y luego me quedan 4 más,
esto me lleva a 54; y luego necesitamos sumar
estos otros 14 bloques azules, entonces sumemos 14
desde aquí: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14. Llegamos hasta allí, entonces agregamos
otros 14, llegamos allí. Y ahora, ¿en qué número
estamos? Bueno, hay dos formas de pensarlo: puedes
ver que tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 arriba
de 60, lo que nos indicaría que estamos en 68;
o puedes ver que estamos dos marcas pequeñas abajo
de 70, que también sería 68. Así que ahora tenemos
68 bloques en total y luego agregamos los 16
bloques morados; hagámoslo, sumamos 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16,
y llegamos aquí. Tenemos mucha suerte, nuestra
recta numérica tiene la cantidad justa de marcas.
Entonces sumamos 16 y podemos ver que tenemos 1,
2, 3, 4 arriba de 80, así que tenemos 84 bloques
en total. Otra forma de pensar en esto es que nos
tomaría dos marcas para llegar a 70, luego nos
quedarían 14, otros 10 para llegar a 80 y luego
nos quedarían 4, y luego llegamos a 84. Por lo
que ahora Carla tiene un total de 84 bloques.